former Trump campaign chief Paul
Manafort has been indicted for crimes
related to lobbying that took place
primarily three to five years ago but
while the charges have nothing to do
with the Trump campaign itself Special
Counsel robert muller may have just
inculpate 'add top Democrats and the
Obama administration will analyze then
finally at long last
roaming millennial is back Alicia Kraus
and His Eminence Paul Bois joined the
panel of deplorable to discuss Kevin
Spacey's gay out of jail free card
John Boehner 'he's bitterness at
republicans and praise for obama
surprise surprise and why SOI boy
BuzzFeed betas have so little
testosterone
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Dole show
[Music]
I can't really knock these BuzzFeed
betas by the way cuz these stupid
glasses make me look like a hipster e
pajama boy but more on that later okay
let's get to the main story the
Democrats have their first scalp former
Trump campaign Chairman Paul Manafort
has been indicted on completely
unrelated charges they also got manna
for its right-hand man Rick Gates and
they've apparently also reached a plea
deal with former campaign adviser George
papadopolis
not to be confused with George Tucker
Leppa guess who is the former Clinton
war whom Clinton spokesman who pretends
to be a journalist on television this is
George papadopolis nobody it seems as
yet pointed out that the indictment
almost certainly inculpates top
Democrats including Hillary's campaign
chairman John Podesta's brother Tony for
context Hillary Clinton was spotted
hobnobbing with Tony Podesta just this
weekend just like two days ago right now
in so much as this indictment suggests
that the Republicans colluded with
Russia
whatever that means we know that the
Democrats colluded with Russia at least
as much and really from all the evidence
available to us the Democrats committed
far graver misdeeds in colluding with
Russia because we now know that Hillary
Clinton and the DNC paid a foreigner
connected with Russia for alleged dirt
on Donald Trump to skew an American
election you know like the thing that
they've been accusing us of for the last
year incessantly yeah they did we have
evidence that they did all of that she
then lied not only about the 12 million
dollar price tag for that document but
she also absurdly denied any knowledge
of it whatsoever the president's
reaction was typically trumpian he said
sorry but this is years ago before Paul
Manafort was part of the Trump campaign
but why aren't crooked Hillary and the
Dems the focus with 5x5 question works
he goes on also there is no collusion in
all caps and Moines exclamation point
now it is worth noting it appears the
president Trump has deleted every tweet
about manna fort from his timeline so
the White House is not happy about this
to say the least
former Trump campaign adviser George
papadopolis is cooperating with the
special counsel and he apparently tried
to set up a meeting with Russian of
officials for the purpose of warmer
American relations with Russia you know
to have a Russian reset or something in
order to and these are his words
increases importance as a policy adviser
to the campaign so we know that some
campaign aid was offered dirt on Hillary
he apparently tried to get his hands on
so what that doesn't who we know the
Democrats did this we know they paid
millions of dollars for this and I won't
even knock them for it I will not knock
Hillary Clinton for her Oppo research
per se I will knock her for the
ridiculous hypocrisy of accusing your
opponents of doing the very things that
you do but every campaign does this
every campaign tries to get Oppo they
try to get dirt on their opponents
that isn't why Papadopoulos struck a
plea deal the crime that he committed
was lying to the FBI this is always a
bad idea to not lie to the FBI you they
will find you and but the focus on
Papadopoulos is a distraction away from
manna for and the Podesta group and why
this case wasn't prosecuted for so long
we're not talking about crimes that
happened six months ago were talking
about crimes that happened five years
ago so why wasn't it prosecuted the
federal government had all of this
information before the election why is
it being prosecuted now the text of the
indictment points to our answer it reads
quote as part of the scheme in February
2012 manna Fort and gates solicited to
Washington DC firms company a and
Company B to lobby in the United States
on behalf of Yanukovych the Party of
Regions and the government of Ukraine
for instance Gates wrote to Company A
that it would be quote representing the
government of Ukraine in Washington DC I
know what you're thinking who exactly
are these elusive companies a and B the
indictment goes on quote to minimize
public disclosure of their lobbying
campaign manif Orton Gates arranged for
the Center for a modern Ukraine to be
the nominal client of company a and B
even though in fact the center was under
ultimate direction of the government of
Ukraine
you knew kovitch in the Party of Regions
tied to Russia
it goes on at the direction of mana
foreign gates company a and Company B
engaged in extensive lobbying who are
they a company IND well we know that
five days ago NBC News reported that
Muller
is investigating democrat lobbyist Tony
Podesta the reason that name rings a
bell is he's the brother of Hillary's
campaign chairman John Podesta met now
this report went on and showed that mana
Ford had organized a PR campaign for
this front group the European Center for
modern Ukraine Podesta's company was one
of the firm's that worked on the
campaign the Podesta group also violated
the foreign agents Registration Act
because it only filed is a foreign agent
when it was exposed that they hadn't so
they got caught and then retroactively
Lee they they registered his one just
this afternoon this broke about an hour
ago
Tony Podesta stepped down from the
Podesta group amid the investigation all
of the available evidence points to the
indictment in co-pay ting not only a
major Democrat firm for undisclosed
lobbying on behalf of Russian interests
not only a major Clinton crony but
actually the brother of Hillary
Clinton's campaign chairman we're
talking about lobbying efforts that took
place between 2012 and 2014 that's at
least three years ago it's up to five
years ago what took so long for the
prosecution well I don't know what do we
know about Barack Obama's executive
agencies during that time we know they
were highly politicized we know they
selectively prosecuted perceived enemies
like Dinesh D'Souza they targeted
conservative Tea Party groups through
the IRS we know they ignored major
scandals like fast and furious Hillary
Clinton's email scandal on and on and on
is it possible that the Obama
administration didn't prosecute this
case for years because it would have
implicated top Hilary cronies in the
run-up to her presidential run the
timing sure does make you wonder for
analysis we bring on our expert panel of
deplorable --zz Alicia Krauss his
eminence Paul Bois and at long last
finally an answer to my prayers the one
and only roaming millennial roaming
welcome back first question to you is
this indictment a win for Democrats or
are Democrats going to hope that they
never called for this special counsel I
would say that it's not necessarily a
win for Democrats so much as a giant
loss for mana for who I think we all
kind of suspected it was was a shady
character oh you see sweetie claim to me
I know you're talking about like that
very heavy angry look at he always
worked connections that were coming out
no I mean
and you know I'm someone who I look at
this and I'd like you said don't think
this directly leads to collusion by the
Trump campaign specifically but I think
you know from what I've seen a lot of
Democratic experts analysis and
commentators aren't really taking it
that way but what I think all these
investors have shown us is that the
corruption and at least the Democratic
Party and their campaigns is definitely
not squeaky clean either and I would
love to say that oh you know this is
great this is gonna increase
accountability for them I don't think
it's gonna change anything really and
you know frankly with this whole who's
who like hot potato game of who's been
collaborating with the Russians I don't
think we're ever I don't know I don't I
don't know if we're ever gonna get that
satisfaction of the vindication of like
big prosecution's like people like
Hillary Clinton actually being held
accountable or I don't know I'm not I'm
not optimistic that anything will change
but I do know that from what I've seen
people who are against Trump the Trump
campaign are very very happy about this
but is it even a big deal I mean we
don't know who colluded with Russia we
don't really know what that phrase means
anymore because well either everybody
did it or nobody did it I mean what's
the meet I'm I'm of course this
apparently made your Trump apologist who
will just defend anything he does but me
too I knew I knew I liked you rubbing
okay but I mean when we actually look at
what some of these things are things
like opposition information and research
personally I wouldn't see that the same
way as like election rigging right and
there is a difference to be had there
and the term colluding with Russians is
pretty big when we're talking about
transferring millions of dollars though
I think that is that is substantial
especially to a foreign entity I think
that brings up questions of campaign
finance laws if nothing else I'm not
sure about the legality of it just you
know just enquiring after I guess
opposition research though that's true
and you know every every campaign has
Oppo research but we know that in this
case Hillary Clinton's campaign gave 12
million dollars to get this Oppo so
that's absolutely Alisha the White House
is insisting that this indictment says
nothing about president Trump earnest
campaign are they lying or is this
indictment to borrow a phrase in nothing
burger I think that it's hard for
both sides to say that this is a nothing
burger but also I think that you're
going to see both sides of friend Carol
Markowitz who writes for the New York
Post brought this up she's like this is
where you see both sides say there's
nothing here and this is where you see
the true fans of both sides truly come
out the Hillary Clinton Democratic you
know DNC fans are gonna say nothing diss
or look at their look at the other guy
and then the Trump people are going to
say oh well he didn't collude there's
nothing to see here ran afore it's a
good guy look at what Hillary and
Podesta did and so I just like to say
chew on other foot we need to hold our
Chaidez accountable as you know we
wouldn't want the Democrats to be and
and I just gotta say this new cycle is
amazing because now Matt Walsh and ben
shapiro and yourself have just used the
names in so many ways although i do
think it's really disappointing I'm a
fan of Sarah Huckabee Sanders as the
White House communications you know
she's much better than then Spicer ever
was but I gotta say like she's now using
an excuse that the Obama administration
used of quote unquote lower-level
staffer remember when we heard that a
time after time I mean next we're gonna
hear that Donald Trump is just finding
out about these things from TV also
another excuse that was often used by
the Obama administration so Sarah I love
you girl but come up with better talking
points about this specific issue because
you're reminiscent of the good old days
of Where's Waldo and he was behind that
same old podium and I think we can
certainly both agree whether you prefer
Sanders or Spicer that they are both
vastly inferior to mr. mooch Anthony
scary-movie the finest mind ever pulled
sort of that position yeah you have a
soft spot in your heart for him don't ya
oh you know it you kidding me is
probably my cousin or something yeah and
as you know also on this what about ISM
we should we should make clear the
indictment on unmanned afford is for
lobbying that went on years ago that
went on between 2012 people strike to
people like myself speculated why would
Donald Trump hire him in the first place
when he had had these connections and
had been known by numerous politicians
and in corporations and groups and
lobbyists etc in DC as a guy that was
Putin friendly and that was a red flag
to a lot of conservatives way back
during the primary and when Donald Trump
hired him in the first place I think it
was just to get through that convention
I think he hired him as a yeah I think
he fired him shortly after the
convention and he
to basically knock out poor old Ted Cruz
but I don't know I mean he had
connections going back a long way to
stone who you know Roger stone also
owned a company with Paul Manafort
so it is murky I agree it is unclear
exactly well you know Corey Lewandowski
is somewhere I don't know what he's up
to nowadays and I don't really care but
he probably woke up really happy this
morning yes because he and mana fort
were known to have at it in Trump Tower
and not get along very well and Ivanka
and Jared Trump sided with Manta for
originally because they'd wanted
Lewandowski out his campaign manager so
it's just I wish I were a fly on the
wall just to see the happenings of of
what the Trump family really thinks
about this behind closed doors and you
know Corey Lewandowski is probably doing
a happy dance christmas came early for
Lewandowski no question
your eminence mr. voix the indictment
lists company and be one of which if I
were a gamblin man I would say is the
Podesta group now they did undisclosed
lobbying for which Manta Ford is being
charged
why hasn't Muller named those companies
why hasn't Tony Podesta been indicted
along with Paul Manafort well we know
from a NBC news report that was posted
in like just about an hour ago that most
likely that the company's a company a
and B is mercury and of course the
Podesta group now my reason as to why II
says a and B could just be because one
of those are named the Podesta group and
that just automatically just puts John
Podesta out there front and center and I
think possibly they just want to keep it
all focused on Manta Ford and the Trump
campaign and as to why John Podesta has
not been indicted yet I mean he has
stepped down we'll wait to see what
materializes in the next couple days to
see if an indictment is on the table
form so we know that Tony Podesta just
stepped down as the head of the Podesta
group amid this investigation do you do
we wonder why this hasn't been
prosecuted until now they had this
information for years it's between three
and five years old
do you think mr. Gua that this has
something to do with the corruption of
the Obama administration and the
up to Hillary Clinton's presidential run
oh absolutely I think so I mean we all
know that this Trump Russia collision
thing is completely cooked up and I
would not be afraid to speculate that
know why would cuz you might end up like
Vince Foster or somebody man no I'm
kidding I'm not gonna get into those
conspiracy theories now we do have to
get into Kevin Spacey cashing in his gay
out of jail free card as well as the
beta males at BuzzFeed but if you're
watching us on Facebook and YouTube you
got to go to daily water calm we can't
give you the rest of the show I'm sorry
you got to go subscribe thank you
everyone who's already been subscribing
you help us keep the lights on
you keep coffe fa in my tumbler for
those of you who don't go to daily
wire.com right now it is $10 a month or
$100 for an annual membership you get me
you get the intro flamin show you get
the Ben Shapiro show yeah I know when is
this over Michael step well how about
this how does that change your mind the
leftist tears tumblr let me tell you
folks on this indictment Monday things
are looking really bad for the Podesta's
and they're throwing Hillary Clinton in
with this too there is going to be a
surplus of leftist tears it's going to
be pouring out of the walls you got to
make sure that you have the appropriate
vessels so that you can collect them and
enjoy delicious salty leftist here as
hot or cold no matter how you like them
so go to daily wire calm right now we'll
be right back
after 58 years Kevin Spacey has finally
cashed in his gay out of jail free card
after being accused of trying to seduce
actor Anthony Rapp 30 years ago when rap
was only 14 Spacey sent out a statement
neither confirming or denying the
incident and then he came out as gay a
revelation only slightly less shocking
than the sky's blueness and waters
wetness roaming
oh I'm sorry I'd like to start with
Alicia actually was Spacey's first
response the response yeah I don't
remember this happen it sounds really
awful by the way I'm gay look over here
I'm gay was that too clever by half or
was it the best response he had to work
with I think that it was a very cynical
but brilliant moved by his PR team
because as we saw the mainstream media
decided to run with the headline as
Kevin Spacey award-winning actor comes
out as gay instead of addressing the
accusations that a now 40 plus year old
actor made about him the from a
molestation attempt when he was 14 years
old I mean it's despicable and it was
also very disturbing for me to read
Spacey's words saying well you know I
was drunk at the time and I don't
remember if this happened or not yeah I
mean we've all probably had a couple too
many drinks and we would know whether or
not something like this happened or had
we perpetrated such a crime it was very
vague and it sexplanations it wasn't
black-and-white he should if he knew
that he wasn't guilty of this and he
could have said no one else you know
these people will vouch for me no one
else can say that this ever happened
this never happened again I'm incredibly
embarrassed you know something but he
didn't really take ownership of it but
he didn't just deny it either and and I
mean I'm not an attorney but from my
layman's view of it it looked as if he
acknowledged that yes the event did
happen but look over here because I'm
finally coming out of the closet and now
we're hearing more and more reports
there's been a lot of people posting on
social media that they have friends and
family members that have also been
assaulted by Kevin Spacey and Netflix
announced just before your show started
Fox News CNN and numerous other outlets
are covering it that house of cards has
been officially cancelled by Netflix
well that should have been cancelled
because the show is no good anymore I
mean it was
was great yeah but it was really I this
season it's my favorite show and I
couldn't even finish it so maybe they
were just looking for an excuse but it
is a lot and this actually brings up a
point I was tweeting out some snarky
comments last night about Spacey and
actually I was a little surprised that
conservatives were so happy that this
guy in particular is going down because
he always struck me as sort of quiet
private doesn't rub his politics in our
face but you know I tweeted out
something to the effect of you know the
gay out of jail free card and all that
sort of snow a gay friend of mine texted
me this morning and he said you know
comments like that are really flippant
and their myopic because this is a
phenomenon that has happened in the gay
community since the ancient Greeks that
confused gay teenagers will look to
older gay guys in their 20s or 30s and
those relationships are prevalent and
they happen and and to pretend that they
don't and to pretend that all gay
relationships should be exactly like
heterosexual relationships or is misses
the point or it's off pitch I don't know
anything about it really I can only take
his word for it now the that this seems
similar to basically what Milo innopolis
was saying and what destroyed his career
you know does I mean when people make
comments like that is it just
apologizing for pederasty or pedophilia
or does our rote reaction risk turning a
willfully blind eye to a phenomenon that
is more common than we think roaming
what do you think well I think just
because the phenomenon may or may not be
common that doesn't mean it's acceptable
permissible or moral right and I think
as a society we in general we tend to
minimize assault or molestation when
it's against young boys and I think
that's awful right and you know just
hearing everything actor's name his
account of the incident I mean you know
he was of this age but he clearly I
think doesn't feel like this was just
this normal thing and it doesn't matter
or you know anything like that this is
something that is very serious and I've
you know I have heard people in the gay
community men in the gay community talk
about these younger older male
relationships as if they're just this
normal thing kind of almost like the
word twink comes from right that's a
time all the time no no this this is
abuse and you know regard
like we can throw around words like
pedophilia pederasty and kind of debate
what like what is the age that it
actually is pedophilia I think
regardless of you know strict
definitions like that when you look at
these are relationships that have an
unequal and uneven power dynamic and
where I think people are taking
advantage of others and I don't think I
don't think it's alright and I really
feel for these young men who are maybe
confusing in these situations who have
these predators who are out to take
advantage of them I think I mean if it's
true that Kevin Spacey this is awful and
I think that even since the Harvey
Weinstein stuff it's been become more
apparent to me via friends and families
and acquaintances and people's stories
of unfortunately how many young men in
our society are sexually assaulted that
really weren't a Garten like the
spotlight wasn't put on them during the
hashtag me to campaign and this is a
problem that exists for men and women in
the country and I think roaming brings
up a really good point that young men
and teenage boys are typically not
looked at as victims I mean we've seen
this with a sexy teacher where were
those teachers exactly and and really
making light of these types of assaults
on young men in the country and I think
it's something that needs to be
addressed for sure mr. Bois I always
kind of like to Kevin Spacey as I
mentioned you know he was a private guy
he's a very good actor he generally
isn't too political
why are someone the rights so gleeful
that he has fallen down uh I think it's
mostly because well by Kevin Spacey
falling down it's exposing the broader
culture of sexual abuse in Hollywood
this is basically morphed now in just a
couple of weeks from Harvey Weinstein to
it's a full-blown scandal in Hollywood
akin to the Catholic Church that
happened over there in a decade ago so
it's it's big and so now no longer
Hollywood can stand on their pedestal
and go lecture us and say oh you you
conservatives need to stop now reality
has finally hit them and the fire is
spreading and I think they just see
Kevin Spacey is just another one they
want to know who's gonna who's gonna
drop next who's gonna be the next big
name just gonna be the next big a Lister
unfortunately you know Kevin Spacey it's
happening too I mean
we've had Ben Affleck be accused of
groping women and doesn't know what
you're in for
why can't we keep Kevin Spacey and
knockout Affleck that guy's such a jerk
about politics well I mean to get into
some more conspiracy theory range here
mostly it's because Ben Affleck is the
frontman for Justice League and I don't
think Warner Brothers really wants their
frontman for one of their top franchises
to fall right now so they're gonna do
everything they can in their power to
ensure the media tries to just downplay
his allegations there's also there's
also a very big difference between a 26
year old man assaulting a 14 year old
boy and Ben Affleck who allegedly was a
serial cheater I mean this is why
Jennifer a lot of the rumors were filled
why Jennifer Garner decided to finally
leave him after a decade of him cheating
on her numerous times inappropriately
groping a woman at a club I mean that I
feel like this is something that we
talked about on an episode of lady
brains over on ricochet with my
girlfriend's the other day
all of us women have been quote-unquote
victims of sexual harassment in the
workplace at some point in our lives
unfortunately but there's a big
difference between a dude trying to
smack your ass excuse my french you know
at a bar when he's drunk and you can
respond to him versus a man luring you
to his apartment picking you up throwing
you on the bed and then attempting to
molest you oh I absolutely agree that
the severity of Spacey's allegations are
far far worse than Ben Affleck I'm just
talking about you know the how far is
the industry gonna go with this I mean
are they gonna take allegations against
Ben Affleck seriously as they've done
other people in the industry because
other executives in the industry and
agents have now been let go immense
harassment allegations or are they just
going to you know stop it with Ben
Affleck and say okay we're not gonna let
him fall so that's mostly well I think
it was specifically with a Spacey thing
more people need to fall because now it
is coming out that it was a known thing
by the cast and crew on his sets to keep
young boys away and that is incredibly
disturbing if it was known by the cast
and crew then it was known by higher-ups
and it was known by agents and it was
known by pair I mean it's it's just it's
appalling to me I would never agree to
work with someone let alone to stay
silent if I knew that that was their
behavior running and I think there
also a big difference in how the media
is treating things like Spacey and
Affleck versus people like wine
Weinstein and there's also Terry
Richardson who is the photographer
because you know these are people who
are generally behind the camera behind
the scenes versus actors who we all know
and can identify in studios have a lot
banking on their faces and their public
image so I think if you know Studios had
to choose between who they want to
protect more I think there would be more
invested in protecting the actors whose
faces and reputation people care more
and know a lot more about then people
behind the camera like Weinstein
that's the asset all right speaking of
abuse and assault we need to get onto
the people assaulting and abusing our
country former GOP House Majority Leader
John Boehner is lashing out at
conservative fellow Republicans like
Mark Levin and Congressman Jim Jordan
while he lavishes preys on Barack Obama
he accused Rush and Sean Hannity of
having gone to the quote dark side he
reserved one word four-letter epithets
for his House Republican colleagues and
Boehner said of Obama quote some would
argue on the right that he did more to
divide the country than to unite it but
I kind of reject that notion because it
wasn't him John Boehner our former
leader ladies and gentlemen roaming does
he have a point or do these stupid
comments just vindicate conservatives
criticism of John Boehner honestly I
think they just vindicate the
allegations that he was a RINO not a
real conservative and I know I'm someone
who also felt very let down by John
Boehner I remember when he was a first
given speaker sure he actually teared up
when talking about how much he loved
small business I don't know if you guys
remember that but he actually did cry
when he was giving his first speech and
in fairness he also cries when he orders
appetizers at lunch so spray-on tan but
just just I think he kind of represents
the you know GOP establishment par for
the course not really looking to change
anything and so I'm actually not
surprised that he's doing this and I see
him the same level as I see people like
John McCain who you know they're just
part of the establishment and they they
look at these I mean people like Trump
but also um other members of the GOP I
don't know people like Ted Cruz or Rand
Paul who aren't really toeing the party
line and I think they care more about
Paul
and protecting the status quo than
actual conservatism I don't even think
of John Boehner as a conservative
anymore quite frankly so I'm not
surprised that he's saying all these
things mm-hmm Alicia or the conservative
media are are we unfair to politicians
regardless of what you think about
Boehner is extremely stupid comments are
we unfair to them you know it's very
easy from a studio with cameras to throw
stones at people who aren't being
conservative enough but these guys have
to go out there appease constituencies
strike deals should we have more empathy
for our Republican politicians I gotta
say I would jump to defend the great one
Mark Levin but I can't wait to listen to
his radio show tonight because I'm sure
and I know that he is more than capable
of doing that for himself and a full
disclosure I did produce a Sean Hannity
radio show for seven years for the great
American and even though Sean and I
sometimes disagree on politics during
the time that Boehner was Speaker Sean
was incredibly fair to then Speaker
Boehner
I personally booked him numerous times
on the Sean Hannity radio show heard on
over 500 affiliates nationwide folks I
even think that Sean helped him with a
couple of reelection things and it and
it is unbelievable now how the tides
have turned and he's like moping and his
whiskey with a cigarette hanging from
his mouth like you know Mark Levine
Levin were so rude to him at the time no
I
and then even even a couple months ago
he did an interview where he talked
about it's all talk radios fault that we
got Donald Trump no the beautiful thing
about this country is our First
Amendment that it allows Michael to sit
there in his grandpa cardigan and say
what he wants cardigan it allows it
allows the great American Sean Hannity
to you know sit in his studio in in New
York and talk about he wants to talk
about and consistently I actually think
that you've seen that talk radio tends
to represent the true voice of
constituents and the true voice of the
American voters far better than John
Boehner ever had a grasp on and that's
why he lost his power mm-hmm absolutely
right mr. wah I have interacted with
many Republican politicians who have
more contempt for their own base than
they do for their opponents do banners
comments validate this ban in
view of the world that we've been seeing
that the politics is not divided between
right and left primarily but primarily
between the people and the elites oh
absolutely
I think so this is the line yeah I think
this is just right in line with the John
McCain's and the Mitch McConnell's just
you know clearly not being a team player
just just throwing people there's
hardworking people under the bus and
turning Trump but to some you know ogre
that's like part of this like ugly
nationalist uh
populist uprising and there's no
legitimacy to it so absolutely
absolutely it only fuels a like like ben
shapiro said this is the reason why
Trump won and it will only fuel his win
in 2020 if they want to keep going like
I'm almost sick and tired of it frankly
as so much winning okay now we have to
get on to our final story today this is
science we don't want to neglect science
on this show we're not science deniers
from our friend Amanda press to joke
about the daily wire in an experiment on
male attractiveness where BuzzFeed
fellas compete to see who's hottest for
males had their testosterone levels
tested not what these are Amanda's words
by the way but they're just so beautiful
not one BuzzFeed beta male met the
average rather all the men testing below
the level of a typical 85 year old male
moreover three of the four men tested
below the average range and the male
with the highest testosterone level you
gene still had a relatively low T score
now this is a really personal issue for
me because these stupid glasses that I
have to wear make me look like a little
soy boy to roaming why does our culture
seem built for pajama boys well you know
what this whole bus sweet thing I saw
this actually yesterday the day before
on Twitter originally and I was shocked
but also not that shocked I mean I kind
of explained everything everything
started to make sense and when I look at
the guys in BuzzFeed they're just the
exact embodiment of what third-wave
feminism wants men to be and wants them
to become right these beta [ __ ] who
have as much testosterone as the ladies
on the view right and that's kind of how
do you really feel
but no seriously uh I look at them and I
look at these test results and I think
they are kind of the I guess the
realization of the current narrative
we're seeing that attacks toxic
masculinity and I think I mean I don't
want to make two broad generalizations
or assume motives or things about people
who may adhere to the progressive
viewpoint but I do think that a lot of
the men I see attracted ah the activist
BuzzFeed Vox whatever HuffPo they do
kind of seem on the lower end of the
testosterone scale and I think that how
much they tend to play into things like
emotion versus things like facts and
logic which tend to be things associated
with higher testosterone masculinity and
men in general which obviously these
BuzzFeed individuals are not do we have
a cut of these guys just for a little
context on what we're talking about here
today we're gonna find out which one of
you guys is the hottest try guy
scientifically of course what actually
makes a man attractive today more than
ever society and media appreciates hot
men like us for instance and we wondered
if that sexiness could be boiled down to
the science we're here to find out if
the prevailing theories about male
beauty have any truth to them and we
hear the test subjects the try guys are
going to be conducting six experiments
we're gonna draw our blood measure our
faces and all sorts of wacky [ __ ] I'm
gonna win all the categories today the
most beautiful beautiful keys in the
rest Marshall can you please destroy
these glasses right can you take forever
you like a nuclear waste site and make
sure that they never see the light of
day again thank you Alicia is this a
generational trend or is this just more
evidence that there is a huge divide
between the American people and these
weird elites that are in media and
journalism and government I mean giving
those guys the benefit of the doubt I
think they were kind of making fun of
themselves yeah it's very humorous I'll
have to go watch the full thing but I
actually think that any conservative men
that are watching your show right now
should be rejoicing because you have to
compete with that and that ain't much
guys
so get out there get married
fruitful multiply this is my plan for
conservatives to take over the United
States again I don't know if I've
mentioned this before the then governor
of Indiana mitch Daniels I was talking
to him one time at an event in Indiana
and we were saying listen that's looking
really dire
although the Obama was president
everything was against us what do we do
how do we how do we win the culture and
win the politics he said well you can
either persuade them or you can find a
nice girl and get married and outbreed
them I promise you the latter is more
fun mister Bois your eminence a study
came out recently which showed that more
effeminate men are also more likely to
be socialists which surprised to get
exactly nobody Oh world now this doesn't
this observation imply that our
political views are not entirely
rational but also shaped us by something
as elemental as hormones or else it just
means that masculine people are more
rational doesn't this throw into chaos
our idea that facts don't care about
your feelings and we have access to
rational truth you know that is a very
interesting question
that's why I asked Appel as far as the
hormones really I mean I certainly is
built into the male character absolutely
that a male character is supposed to the
male is supposed to lay his life on the
line for the sake of his community and
his family and his wife and I think the
moment that that identity has gone out
the window which certainly has in the
past 50 years and man and males are just
basically sitting around and pleasuring
themselves and consuming things I think
the more effeminate by the way I just
have to cut you off there do you have a
camera in my apartment if you put a
camera in my apartment Paul take it out
right now it's a crime home only men are
always going to be males and they're
always going to have that aspect that
that natural part of it but the
socialization of them of turning that
into that energy that power into
something that that's useful once that
goes away essentially what you're going
to have is just basically a bunch of
boys overgrown boys and that's that's
what happens
are our hormones are they controlling
our thought processes are we just little
people riding on the big elephant of the
subconscious or can we rely on our
faculties of reason I think we can rely
on our faculties of reason and I don't
think hormones mean that you know no one
is logical known as rational I just
think hormones mean that some people who
tend to be more feminine and effeminate
males or women in general rely less on
their faculties right and we've seen
this in multiple studies men and you
know people who are more masculine
whether it's men or women in terms of
like their hormone levels they they're
more rational more logical they care
more about facts and you know hormones
like estrogen which women have in
abundance and apparently the BuzzFeed
men probably do as well that tends to
make people more emotional and more into
feeling and things like that and I think
when we look at leftist arguments a lot
of them are based on emotions versus
actual hard fact a lot of them are
trying to make government into some big
compassionate family which is generally
the domain and realm of women's so you
know I I don't think it's that no one's
thinking everywhere we're all just
slaves to our hormones I think it's just
that for our hormones kind of guide how
much or little we depend on our facts
and logic and for some people that's a
very very little roaming millennial
channeling Jack Nicholson in as good as
it gets how do you write women so well I
think the man that is all the time we
have for today we've we've covered all
of the most important news right down to
the soy boys panel thank you for being
here roaming millennial one of our
earliest panelists a our dear favorite
and dealer is Alicia crass Daily wires
his eminence Paul blah I am Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
come back tomorrow we'll do it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
associate producer is Bailey Lynn the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017